[Music]
as covid cases continue to surge across
nevada the efforts to get more people
vaccinated is ramping up
a free drive-through site is offering
shots and vaccines for the second week
in a row
and many were out in full force today
madison kimbrough was there and joins us
live in the newsroom
with the latest madison yes people took
full advantage of the services offered
at unlv's stan fulton building today
as the drive-through testing and
vaccination site just closed for the day
about 30 minutes ago
according to staff i spoke to the goal
is to have this testing site open
until the end of september operating on
a first-come first-served basis
while supplies last i feel it's very
convenient for a lot of people to be
able to you know come here and be able
to simply just
stay in the cars and have a drive
through
it's faster clark county and the
southern nevada health district have
come together with
other county organizations to provide
free drive through covet 19 testing and
vaccinations to the masses
as case numbers rise across the county
this drive-through method makes it
extremely convenient for those to get
tested or vaccinated
i'm fully vaccinated but we just came
back from vacation
so it's more of a precautionary thing
for both of us because we don't want to
bring
something back to people that we're
going to be around the site has about
300 doses of vaccine and 500 tests
each night of operation that's sunday
through thursday from 5 30 pm to 10 30
p.m
many people have been arriving early to
get a good spot in line
i was told that they're going to start
at 5 30 and to be here around
four so i can be one of the first there
will be three covet vaccines available
pfizer moderna and johnson and johnson's
jansen which is one shot
vanessa rodriguez who waited in line
says it's vital for her family to do
their part
after experiencing so much loss due to
this virus
my husband and my father passed away
within 24 hours of each other so
for us the the services being offered
and us taking advantage of it and just
making sure like i said to keep
everybody around us safe
and officials suggest that if you do
come out register online before
at the southern nevada health district
website this will help the line move
faster
also if you want to get tested or
vaccinated there is a walk-up option
at this site too reporting live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news now